a lot of these stereotypes actually come
from sexist beliefs because there is no
biological difference between males and
females that indicates whether or not
they can drive or cook well these
stereotypes are exclusively because of
the beliefs that people have had in the
past about gender roles there are some
so
boring in reality such as the idea that
men are stronger this can still be
really toxic and sexist and is not
always true but biologically men tend to
find it easier to build muscle because
of their hormones therefore making them
often stronger men can cook and clean
women can drive and as for childcare
some people like make the argument that
breastfeeding is a biological difference
but that kind of stops after the age too
so men can look after children too you
can do whatever you want gender doesn't
really matter it's sexist most
stereotypes and I'm not going to say all
but with most stereotypes they are not
proscriptive they are descriptive okay
it is society noticing things about
groups of people and commenting on it